o meu deu certo já tá aqui de novo e aí
olha que no final tudo com vocês vão
entender que a faculdade este meu canal
nesses canais só existe um filho que
está no canal e agora poderá ver esse
vídeo aqui tava chovendo forte obstar a
van dele então não sei se vocês sabem
mas eu pratico o esporte de luta uma
itajaí vai fazer três anos só volta dois
anos e onze meses eu sempre gostei que
ela sempre gostei porrada osso quebrado
só de carne negro saiu de maca sim para
ter respostas e depois que acabou de
ligar a televisão e vou dormir porque
não está mesmo na a selar acho chato
assim o fato de alguém me arrebentar eu
meio que o nosso muito sábio de apanhar
e alguém me batendo com o pw dente acho
chato acho chato desnecessários nessa
muitos necessário muito nessa mas enfim
brincadeiras à parte e abrir uma
academia de lutas marciais e que meu
bairro são vito resolvi entrar porque é
bom assim eu sempre digo alguém a
praticar alguma arte marcial não para
bater em ninguém não pra fazer o mal sim
mas pra só que defesa para talvez até
pra manter a saúde manter a forma depois
que entrei na academia eu comecei a
perceber as coisas engraçadas que eu
perguntava você já percebeu que sempre
tem um amigo da gente fica impressionado
já depois do primeiro dia de treino a
sério depois do primeiro dia de treino
acaba já sai da rua acham que é bruce
lee dos sertões
pois é para você parece que anda a droga
está preocupado com o seu velho lica
takagui galera adaptadora toque moleque
fpf a imitar a amiga que é meu brother
entendendo não fazendo mais type olha
fica bom mesmo por exemplo que isso vai
ficar na minha mão já batido caquetá
tarde ele tudo é vilã
o cara estava atrás de mim e assim eu
posso fazer isso na cara do mundo é
transformar o nome dele eu sei lá o papa
quem pensa que sabe fazer toda a arte
marcial não sabe o chamado na primeira
mão sabe que ele me deu eu peguei já dei
logo um ippon quadradinho de outros
8 foi um novo golpe inventei ariel é o
cara fica rebolando aguda assim o cara
que notícia mexe com todo mundo e isso é
óptimo mas é isso aí posto aparece na
academia eu pensei que estava usando a
droga não pode é ele caiu lá na praça
não é mais taiko é é luta na veia é
brigando aí que vocês têm me ouvir e
talvez chegar livre que também falou e
falou para falar tardio para falar
tardio para executá lo
a gente está usando droga mesmo chega a
fechar e já seguiu no pique de ficar
aqui no primeiro dia de treino já que é
o prosseguir e também aquele carro que
no primeiro dia de treino já que
apressar as coisas até dá um mortal
triplo x apagadinho de 8k padre 1 do
santos é o apressado quentin não só
pessoal pois o aquecimento
eu já contei à tarde
chega o papel aqui é botou na cabeça do
cara do outro lado mesmo dia terrível há
10 por nada falava olha aqui
outra pessoa que eu não tenho e sempre
tem uma academia de empreendedores é o
tipo de pessoa que eu chamo de super
chineiro que a pessoa que no bota fé e
qualquer pessoa que seja melhor do que
ela pessoal vamos ficar diz do player
lá não tem outra ordem é clara eu devo
voltar a treinar
eu acho que o ladrão é que ele pega e
falar ela também corre vai chegar e vai
dar um soco nele aqui vai rolar ainda
estão lá vamos lá que citaram uma
daquelas apuramento apanhar de um ladrão
de campanha sob de gaia foi a copa do
mundo acabou 11 mais fumar por exemplo
muito forró
o treinamento da memória então a a só
provou já seguindo a sip também a pessoa
que superestima também tem outro é
aquela pé até uma pessoa formada sabe
aquela pessoa não é só eu sei o que eu
faço é para não se fazer se não já fiz
nada de um fofo thai jiu jitsu tudo está
bem no tempo até para fazer tudo isso aí
vou fazer para ter um braço a etapa
outro que eu ia se conhece
é coisa sobrenatural falar de um segundo
túnel eu sei eu sei mas vamos começar
vamos começar da base depois de
desenvolver a técnica você acha dessa
ferramenta que ela tomou um choque
grande profissional não se fala mais em
que a resistente à água que fazem a
massagem é eu tava difícil entender o
que fazer em favor da lei e até eu vou
fazer que está rodando mas eu não canso
dessas coisas comigo não vou fazer
pensar
só que esse tipo de pessoa nas primeiras
existir uma mulher dura até aqui o
atlanta hawks
ópera ou não não gosto de rótulos
a mulher então ligou porque eu só parei
conexão 90 fechado mas sim mas só dez
minutos o prudente começou o treinamento
é nesse dia que eu também fiz a cada
1.000 identifiquei um tipo de pessoa que
eu me identifiquei muito tenho certeza
que você também identifica que aquela
pessoa que fantasia só por você está
sendo melhor você não pode ver um árvore
que tem uns pau assim ó seja acho que é
uma pessoa na casa sem fantasia se
imagina uma pessoa que fica é o que eu
chamo de lutador imaginar
[Música]
hum
o time só me só rodam por exemplo a mãe
ainda pode esquecer é claro do mentiroso
sempre tem alguém na academia que meti
mateus sá tornando-o cada pergunta ou
não eu já fiz tudo que é nosso querido
preguiçoso é aquele que sempre dá um
jeito de dar uma porrada nas coisas 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 camisa do flamengo
era não sei se vocês gostam de esporte
não sei quais vocês praticam o esporte
mas aquele que deixou a galera que gosta
de arte marcial ou que pelo menos gosta
de assistir um filme de luta era tipo eu
chegar na loja de videogames para
perguntar o que é que ele joga palácio
band luta e saberão nó foto de duda tem
um sorteio é a página do facebook pão
fighters está fazendo um sorteio de um
kit de judô ou o kit de caráter ou um
kit de mma e se esqueçam caro pra
[ __ ] que o equipamento mais top que o
lutador pode ter se você não gosta de
luta você também pode participar porque
como é caro você pode ganhar e vender
para alguém
outro presente algum amigo seu que luta
um irmão para em seu que luta aqui na
descrição do vídeo tem passo a passo
como você deve fazer sua participação se
você sair de bombeiros e foi na van
vão ganhar um kit de luta para pagar é
só seguir os passos do que tá com a
descrição do vídeo e você já está
participando se você pratica alguma luta
se você já pratica alguma luta começa
aqui em baixo alguma história engraçada
que aconteceu e é isso aí
se você ainda não está inscrito nacional
clique em inscrever-se toda vez que
tiver um vídeo novo você vai saber então
é isso aí galera muito obrigado podendo
então é isso aí galera muito obrigado
por ter assistido vir até aqui ea outra
[Música]